I thought this was probably the biggest
madman last year was the IQ test so
momenta Brent to an IQ test
you know Brett's our resident expert on
everything and momenta anybody who
listens he's always a smartest guy in
the room so they decided that they were
gonna take an IQ test to see would score
higher but there was a lot of
trash-talking before it all started I
loved the trash-talking the funniest
most disingenuous persons were - Brent
is just a big you know fake tough guy
you're the worst employee here I am the
silent martyr here a shitbird I just
like to point out a different way of
thinking he's the most full of himself
person that works any delusional person
that works here there's no one on this
staff who's gone to a better college
than me had a better education than me I
think he's a narcissistic sociopath that
has the personality of Ted Bundy I don't
want to be the one to have to take Brent
down narcissus over here seems to humble
me I wish that there were people here
who could do it who had the educational
background thinks the whole world
revolves around him wow that was a very
bitter IQ but we get the results my met
one it wasn't even close it was 121 -
112 we were all shocked because most of
the office quite honestly was betting on
Brent
so here's the moment we announce the
results a person with the superior
intelligence is with a 1:21 Manette
Walker
Wow there was such glee and his boys he
was very happy a lot of real but his
victory speech was ridiculous and of
course he said a lot of things that he
wished he didn't say and then he had to
apologize john hein
you are the [ __ ] king but guess what
you're sucking my dick today baby
John I apologize for you telling you to
suck my dick okay I don't mean that you
want John to suck your dick I said that
during my acceptance speech Wow
gracious winner then he did the same
thing with nawicki assaulted a man that
apologized
Steve nawicki Steve nawicki you gummy
smiled little prick I'm taking the top
of the best looking back you [ __ ] it
up okay he told me I was gonna lose this
test so I'm taking the title back I
don't think he has a gummy smile I only
said cuz someone called in and said that
I was mad but no wiki had a great
comeback you're damaged and you're a
genius and I can hold an erection when I
[ __ ] a woman
[Music]
at least my dick words do [ __ ] Jewish
but Georgina genius having anything
Wow just anger and and viciousness
abound on this show then he had to
apologize to you Howard because he had
spent a lot of time saying that the
entire thing was rigged before the
results I know and then he won and then
suddenly it wasn't rigged with tears oh
yeah you see Robin you don't need
year-in-review you remember I feel like
I owe you an apology
go ahead why I'll take it but I even
went to like the I have a card on my
desk view I've got at one o'clock in the
morning and grabbed a card to write you
an apology no are you crying
I get emotional with you like I feel bad
you could be a man and there was a
completed apologize to everyone all four
people then he apologizes to you Robin
there's a love/hate thing going on do
you think she wants you - deep down I'm
not saying consciously but doesn't
everyone want you I've said this before
I'm dealt with women who treat me the
way Robin treats me always it turns out
they're trying to get in bed with me
Robin it was it was scummy to say Robin
wants to bang me I'm sorry but it was
only because he qualities what you
believe well there you go
what at 2018 moment why does he talk so
much when he has to retract every
statement every statement was retracted
then we couldn't find one statement he
didn't pour apologies there